what are the various sources of
information
that you project and others project at
the table that convey information well
there's several different things there's
the ones that are conscious and then
there's the ones that are subconscious
right like on the conscious level it
might be something someone says right
you know you ask them a question and
they say oh you know you shouldn't call
me here you should so there's the verbal
tells there's also the more you know
subconscious stuff body posture right
the eyes the throat the pulse
um various things that are you know less
controllable I find I use a combination
of both to try to gain information but
generally when I have somebody more
comfortable they give off more when like
everyone has a different approach Phil
Ivey likes to intimidate I go the other
way I want my opponents to be relaxed so
that they'll give me more in that regard
so Phil Ivey likes to perturb the system
like mess with it to see what comes out
I think Phil has an aura about him where
he wants you to know that he's watching
you be a afraid be uncomfortable because
when you're uncomfortable I got you
right and that's sort of his shtick
where he you know and people do like
when you sit at a table with Phil Ivey
it's it's intimidating he likes to rule
by fear and you like to rule by uh what
is it love that's a really good way to
put it I never had anyone put it like
that but it makes a lot of sense yeah
you know fear Phil Ivy and then with me
that's fine don't worry I'll take your
money but you're gonna enjoy it it's
great so that's what the talking at the
table is about is get him to be relaxed
and get some of that gray area between
the Consciousness and the subconscious
to reveal something yeah there's that
too and also just you know and this is
just part of who I am anyway like I like
to talk to people but one of the
byproducts is the more I know about you
the more I likely know about how you
think about different situations right
so what do you do for a living oh I'm a
lawyer I defend criminals okay so this
guy probably spends a lot of his time
twisting the truth trying to find you
know and then so then you know you
already have a mindset of like this guy
might be more likely to Bluff where he's
probably comfortable doing that very
subtle things like that and you start to
uh pick up cues on what nervousness
looks like for this person what the
nervousness communicates all that kind
of stuff so we're talking about physical
tells here yeah physical
to secondary things I was more specific
like player profiling right instead of
understanding the type of mind that I'm
dealing with right
um so again somebody who's a lawyer is
is used to trying is is fine with being
deceptive as part of a game right
whereas maybe somebody's a Sunday school
teacher and you know they don't feel
comfortable they maybe they think
bluffing might be dishonest right so
they're less likely to try some
Shenanigans against you so and then the
other thing too is what type of person
is this in terms of their
um you know out like view on life right
are they positive do they feel like
things go their way or they're not right
there's those people that always well of
course I lost I always lose with this
hand and those types of people you can
manipulate because when a card comes
that you don't you don't have them beat
right but you can pretend because
they'll believe it like of course you
beat me so you bet all your chips
against them knowing that you can scare
them because they're they they already
feel like they're gonna lose the
inherent like the cynicism exactly
cynicism is easier to play against
because you can convince them that their
cards suck yeah when somebody believes
that they're a loser or they're unlucky
right and that bad things happen to them
always and they never catch a break well
you know you can just help them make it
true
what do you think about the rounders
Teddy KGB when he does the Oreo tell do
players at the high level communicate
that kind of stuff do you think it's
realistic to be able to have a tell like
this that's partially subconscious so
first of all I love Brian koppelman who
made the film and uh I think what they
were going for is something obvious to
the general visually right like okay
it's very clear you know he eats the
cookie he doesn't eat the cookie and it
means one or the other at the highest
levels something that you know blatant
you're not gonna find you're gonna find
a lot more subtle things maybe with
posture or or timing or you know
different things like that but at the
lower levels you know you know you might
see some you might see you know with a
lot of people when they're in a hand and
they've bet whether they drink water in
the hand is going to tell you something
generally speaking it's such an intimate
part of the human experience that I feel
like if you have food you're going to
reveal something about yourself through
the way you eat I feel like that's a
dangerous thing to have at the table
well the thing is generally speaking
people don't eat food in the middle of a
hand like they're not gonna bet and then
just like I need Burgers right what they
will do though is you know they bet and
it's up to you and then they're whether
they're on you know uncomfortable or
they do it unconsciously they just want
to do something to make themselves look
relaxed or whatever and you know they
grab a water where they don't really
need it in that moment but they're
trying to take your mind off of the
situation
so they they in the movie wanted to show
a simplistic version of something that
does happen something that's visually
sort of uh clear yeah because I think
one of the things rounders got right is
that it's a poker movie right but you
don't have to be great at poker really
understand poker to enjoy the movie and
that you know Oreo cookie tell like
everyone gets that they're like okay
that's simple if he would have went with
something more subtle you know like
licking your lips or looking to the
right and I think it might have been
lost on the audience and they didn't
actually explicitly
say that that was a tell I don't think
they thought they did everything to let
you know right with the music and slow
motion and he's staring at it and he's
like aha yeah but they didn't actually
say you know this is an obvious tell
like uh my famous characters at the very
end of it yeah you know after he he says
how the [ __ ] did you lay that down
monster right and he's like he's he's
like he's like you're not hungry not
hungry KGB he's like I keep on you know
he sort of references it and then he
takes the cookies he notices he's like
ah he got me and he breaks the you know
the racket well probably if you had that
kind of tell on him you wouldn't in Matt
Damon's character would not reveal well
he says in the movie he says normally I
wouldn't reveal a tale but I don't have
that much time like I've got to Rattle
him some way yeah so that that was one
way to do that how hard is it to do that
to uh in the KGB accent uh to lay down a
monster in those situations in general
how hard is it to lay down a really
strong hand just psychologically yeah no
I mean I think it's incredibly difficult
for the vast majority of people you know
part of what makes professionals really
really good is recognizing a situation
that's very very dangerous and they need
to you know jump ship like what happens
to a lot of players is you get married
to a hand let's say you have pocket aces
which is the best possible hand right
but the board runs out where it's seven
eight nine and then there's a Jack and
then there's a six it's like you have a
great hand to start but you don't
anymore so one of the difficult things
for the average player is you know once
they've put money in cutting their
losses and saying okay let's move on to
the next hand it's very very difficult
thing for a lot of people at every stage
of like pre-flop all the way through be
able to just make a decision on at that
point so yeah essentially not being
attached okay I've already put in forty
thousand dollars in this pot and this
guy's bet another 20. well I mean I got
to get my 40 back right except you know
in some cases you have to reassess
individually this situation and realize
all right well this is a bad investment
so I got to cut my losses